so let's talk about what you should do
at the first sign of dementia
now what are the first signs of
dimension
number one loss of navigation spatial
memory now what is that that has to do
with
locating yourself in time and space so
let's say for example
you're trying to figure out where did i
park my car are you having
problems with direction when you're
driving somewhere and you're
completely and utterly dependent on the
gps
all right number two is um
it's taking you longer to find the right
words number three
you're more easily confused now of
course
there's a lot of things in life that
we're confused about but if you just to
compare
your past to the present is there
some type of drop in clarity i mean that
could be one thing
number four you're repeating yourself
now there's many other symptoms of
dementia but
these are the early signs dementia in
alzheimer's
is a situation where your neurons cannot
get
fuel anymore specifically glucose
because
there's either resistance of fuel going
through the blood-brain barrier
or the neurons in the brain itself
cannot get
fuel anymore so there's a problem with
these synapses
connecting if the blood
has glucose and ketones together which
is a different source of fuel
the brain will prefer
and take as priority the ketones
over glucose so in other words the
preferred
fuel of the brain is ketones which is
the byproduct of
fat burning and very rarely does an
average person
run their body on ketones they're
running their body on glucose and then
what happens they start having
insulin resistance and all sorts of
issues so now that doesn't work anymore
and so the most important thing you need
to know is you need to start feeding the
brain
ketones okay ketones will
bypass this damaged mechanism of the
glucose being absorbed
and feed the neurons directly so you're
going to notice
a nice change in these symptoms for the
better
so how do you increase ketones three
ways you lower your carbs
get on a healthy keto eating plan you
start doing fasting
i have a link down below of how to do
intermittent fasting
going on low carbs will increase ketones
a certain amount
but when you're doing fasting you
greatly elevate the amount of ketones
that the brain can use
now the other thing you can do is a
transition step and to enhance this
process
is to start taking mct oil which will
give you ketones directly
you can also take exogenous ketones in a
tablet form
they're a little more expensive this is
a lot less expensive
but the key is getting more ketones in
the brain
that is going to immediately start
turning things around for you
some other things that i would recommend
dha
this is a healthy fat it's an omega-3
fat
it's in fatty fish it's in caldera oil
a good portion of your brain is made
from this
zinc and vitamin b1
vital for supporting certain parts of
your brain
that can regenerate like the hippocampus
so
get your b1 from nutritional yeast get
your zinc from
shellfish or a good supplement or even
beef
or organ meats it's much more
bioavailable
but vitamin b1 and zinc directly support
the hippocampus which is part of the
brain
that is severely damaged when you have
alzheimer's
the other thing you have to realize is
that if you have dementia there's
probably some hypoxia going on which
means that you have
a lack of oxygen or part of the brain
this is not getting
the blood flow it needs so exercise
is vital to increase oxygen as well as
doing
hyperbaric oxygen therapy and there's
even a therapy
of restricting the brain of oxygen while
you exercise
but you would do that intermittently to
increase oxygen
which will increase stress and cause
your blood to carry more oxygen so
that's another therapy but let's focus
just on exercise right now and
potentially
doing the hyperbaric the other thing
that's really important is getting
enough sleep
if you have a sleep problem like sleep
apnea for example
that can create hypoxia and
decrease the oxygen to the brain or if
you're getting a lack of sleep that
instantly increases your risk for
pre-diabetes insulin resistance and
other health
issues and so one way to kind of reset
your sleep patterns is to start taking
vitamin d and take it
probably minimally at 10 000 iu's every
single day
and you're going to find that you're
going to start sleeping better that's
just one thing there's many things but
that can definitely help you as well as
just taking vitamin d in general which
directly improves brain function
all right there you have it and if you
want some additional information i have
a lot of videos
on the brain check them out i put them
down below
before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on keto
and you need a debug because it's not
going as smooth i have a keto consultant
standing by
to help you this is just for the people
in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call but i put the
number down below
so you can call and get some help